I was in Washington DC this past weekend
I got back very late last night I was
taping a concert special for TNT called
Christmas in Washington
all right nits hey is kind of a big
event the first families there to do it
yeah and the South Korean pop star psy
was there guess what song he's saying
got it tune in to find out I'm hoping
for a little drummer boy
what but what but little drummer boy
well this is absolutely true we didn't
touch this photo or anything nice this
is absolutely real the AAP just released
a press photo from the big finale
this thing doesn't air what is it air
Jeff Oh 21st okay it airs the 21st but
the AAP just released a press photo of
the big finale where the first family
and all the celebrity guests and a choir
are all singing Christmas songs this is
the picture that came out I thought
[Applause]
I you know I thought I was singing a
normal Christmas carol like everyone
else but I guess they call me at the
moment my aorta exploded
I don't know what's going on there if
I'm hitting a high note like maybe
there's a member of the Armed Services
performing some sort of maneuver on you
from behind team I don't know
well anyway going on
I don't know that pictures gonna haunt
me the rest of my life that's what it
looks like yeah Christmas
I see people being happy I'll see that
the people of who-ville don't get any
presents
[Applause]